hello everyone I'm Alana welcome to my
channel and today I am catching up on
the Super Mario Bros movie direct second
trailer I know there was a full direct
I'm just gonna watch the trailer because
stick is so busy right now also I'm
using my phone to record the video
because it's very dark in here
and the laptop built-in webcam is not
doing a great job with that because I'm
not at my home setup so hello to my
phone I hope this works
um I don't know what I'm expecting from
this trailer but I actually was
pleasantly surprised by the last one in
that look I found Chris Pratt's voice
very off-putting it's so weird it's so
hard to have a character whose voice is
so iconic and so burnt into our brains
for many many years and then have it
come out sounding like Chris Pratt it's
weird it's really weird it doesn't mean
he's a bad actor it's just really weird
but for the last trailer I thought it
was really funny like funnier than I
expected I really liked the animation so
I'm like kind of mixed this movie could
be really good I don't know let's watch
the next trailer I'm excited to see it
okay
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Shigeru Miyamoto hi I
love you
today I'm excited for you all to see the
second trailer for The Super Mario
Brothers movie me too
the first trailer we released in October
was seen by lots and lots of people
around the world uh-huh
thank you all for supporting this movie
it's almost finished and I'm not
supposed to say anything else about it
I love him so much let's introduce our
special guests
okay
thank you miyamoto-san it's my pleasure
to introduce Anya Taylor Joy the
incredible actor who voices Princess
Peach Anna Taylor Joy is it on YouTube
it's important for us to work with
performers who could inhabit a wide
emotions to connect with audiences on
the big she's also a very good actress
Anya brings another dimension was Anna
whether she's leading her toads or going
head-to-head against the king
I'm delighted to introduce you to your
princess
I learned Nintendo
direct it really is oops we
a week away from
Sierra's time and I personally could not
be more excited I hope that you enjoyed
the movie as much as I enjoyed working
on it here we go
nice thank you very much
let's look forward to this since the
casting process I thought she'd be
perfect for Princess Peach I'm also
looking forward to this person's
performance playing Donkey Kong is Seth
Rogen
it hi there I'm Seth Rogen same costume
I've been a fan of the world's created
by miyamoto's son in fact my dog is
named Zelda
ever since I was a kid playing uh play
Choice 10 I remember looking at Mario
Brothers and thinking why do I believe
him
but I didn't believe crap
and I'm happy okay well I didn't believe
that true that pause thank you and Zelda
does too
thanks that's son
in my neighborhood there's a cat named
Mario and a dog named Koopa oh okay then
let's press the start button again cute
okay let's go
[Music]
Maris and nicolasia
oh my God okay
toad is so good not sure if you know who
I am
but I'm about to rule the world wow
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
you think I know everything very pretty
fun coming
together we oh my God that outfit stop
that monster oh my God look at us
horrible oh I got this no problem
get it out get it out get it off
cute man it's cute I don't know
there's a huge Universe out there
there's a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us hello
Charlie Day's so good a lot of this is
really good costume no pressure
I would have expected Princess Peach to
be a little bit more high-pitched as
well I guess
nice very good nice yeah
I think the movie looks like fun I
registered that it's probably going to
be very childish although a kids movie
but that's okay as long as you don't
make kids movies
it looks like we'll be able to see a new
side of Princess Peach played by Anya
Sunday
Donkey Kong was there too it's been over
40 years since the release of the
original Donkey Kong game which was also
my debut title we've also changed his
design for the first time since
the original Donkey Kong
so if you might have noticed but for
this movie we seize the opportunity to
give him a comical personality and
design reminiscent of the original
character
what do you think
well that's all for now
I hope you're all looking forward to the
Super Mario Brothers movie thanks man
thank you
so
I think that I found Chris Pratt's voice
a little bit more tolerable this time
maybe it's that I'm used to it or it's
that we actually heard things Mario
would say that let's uh was not my
favorite but like he did a hahaha and a
whoop or something
which is great
um
I still like keep thinking about that
clip where
Chris Pratt I think it was like the
announcement he was like it's a me a
Mario that's not the voice
but it is that voice like it just is
that voice it does just sound like Chris
Pratt who's trying to sound slightly
Italian-American and I I can't get up
with that it's really strange
um all right let's check out what the
internet thought shall we
liking the fact that this doesn't seem
to be just a story vaguely inspired by
the Mario universe but actually directly
incorporating aspects of games from
Smash Bros Mario Kart that's very true
yeah it is a cool cool touch
keeps looking better and better okay
every Mario game you can think of is
going to be in this movie I do hope
there are a lot of references which I
suppose yeah actually didn't occur to me
before this particular trailer
um because they don't really need to do
that but it's a nice touch Jack Black
Killing it as Bowser strongly agree
I wasn't expecting him to have such a
fitting voice for the character truly
seems more medicine than I'm used to he
is also a very good actor that one I'm
not surprised by it all
in Spanish dog toad says leave them
alone he's already dead that's amazing
okay again comments seem really positive
but I tend to be having a thing at the
moment where
um when I'm doing these like trailer
reactions and I think then I look at the
comments the comments are almost always
positive and I'm not sure if that's like
some new YouTube algorithm thing like
maybe if I go to newest first
um I just keep getting entirely positive
comments which doesn't give you a very
good
actual read on it but I don't really
know why that's happening Summit
I don't know what I expected oh man
can't get behind the voice for peach
yeah I I think she's a really good
actress and I really like her
um I don't love the voice of peach
either so
the voices from Mario and for peach
aren't really fitting in my head very
well but I guess as I have always said
adaptations don't need to be one to one
if I wanted the games I play the games
right
um but I just feel like Peach I'm often
used to being a lot more princessy yeah
oh no
where is uh Anya Taylor Joy apparently
it's not Anna
um has a pretty deep voice like me
so it's uh
it's also a little bit of a shift and
doesn't necessarily suit that character
to what we're used to but
it's just gonna take a while to click
with to see that as Peach I think um
again same as Mario
thank you Mario but I'll move he's in
another theater that's technically a
negative
voice acting selection is still whack
Peach sounds more like Rosalina Peach is
supposed to sound like Minnie Mouse
agree with that yeah she does smell like
more like uh Rosalita
I do enjoy the end do you enjoy the
animation but the voices to the animated
characters aren't the most animated
sounding I can see that
yeah they don't they hide
almost entirely if not entirely Screen
Actors and of course green actors can
also do VA but uh they do just sound
like actors in a scene a lot of the time
rather than act as in an animated movie
which is an interesting one oh full of
work nonsense you think the Super Mario
Bros movie is going to be full of woke
nonsense
you're upset about woke nonsense
and but it's uh but it's literally a
magical Mushroom Kingdom all right well
that's why we don't read the negative
ones
there's a lot of really mixed comments
good ad
spicy take is that I'm like the stuff
that I really like about it I think it's
gonna be fun I think it's very hard to
get past some of those casting choices
they hurt my brain a little bit
um the animation looks really cool it
looks very pretty
I'm not convinced right but I am
cautiously optimistic which I guess is
how I try to approach most things rather
than like hatefully or angrily but my
stance right now is like
this could be good
but I'm not gonna get my hopes up